So, now that we've got utility fine,
and we've got this pi star to fine,
we can actually do an even better
job of writing out pi star.
And let me do that.
All right, so
does this equation make sense, Michael?
>> Let's see, so the policy,
is that a star again, or is that a K.
>> That's a star.
So it's the optimal policy.
>> All right.
The optimal action to take at a state
is, well, look over all the actions,
and sum up overall the next states,
the transition probability,
so that's the probability
we end up in state s prime.
And now we have the utility of s prime,
the problem being that
that's not defined.
>> Well, it sort of is,
we defined it immediately above,
at least with respect to some policy.
>> But
that's concerning because we don't know.
The policy that you want to put in there
is gotta be the policy that you're
trying to find.
>> Right, so in fact implicitly
what I mean here is pi star.
So, in fact, let me write that down that
whenever you see me write from now on,
the utility of a state,
I'm almost always going to actually mean
the utility of the state if
I follow the optimal policy.
We might call this the true
utility of the state.
>> I see.
>> So I'm just going to write this off
to the side here as something for
you to remember.
So this this says then that the optimal
policy is the one that, for
every state, returns the action
that maximizes my expected utility.
>> With regard to the optimal policy,
it feels rather circular.
>> It is rather circular, but
you're a computationalist.
You're a big fan of recursion.
We just went through a whole exercise
where we figured out the geometric
series by effectively doing recursion.
>> It's a similar kind of situation,
for this?
>> It kind of is.
So, let me write one
more equation down and
then you'll be one step
closer to actually seeing it.
Of course, if we're in an infinite
horizon with a discounted state,
even though you're one step closer
you won't actually be any closer.
Well let's worry about
that when we get there.
So let me write one more equation down.
>> We're never going to get there.
It's infinitely long.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> Wait are you
demonstrating something with
this lesson by making
it infinitely long?
>> [LAUGH] I'm certainly demonstrating
something with this lesson.
I don't know what it is.
So let me write this next equation down.
So then the true utility
of a state s is then,
I'm just basically going to
unroll the equation for utility.
It's the reward that I get for
being in that state, plus I'm now
going to discount all of the reward that
I'm going to get from that point on.
Got it?
>> All right, so
once we go to our new state s prime,
we're going to look at
the utility of that state.
Okay, that's sort of fine,
modular recursion.
We're going to look at overall actions,
which action gives us
the highest value of that.
Oh I see, that's kind of like
the pi star expression just above.
>> Yup.
All right, so once we figure that out,
we know what action we're going
to take in state s prime.
We're going to discount that,
because why?
Because I guess that just
kind of ups the gamma
factor on all the rewards in the future.
>> Right.
>> And then we're going to add
to that our immediate reward.
Yes, okay I think I follow that.
>> In some sense all I've done is
I kept substituting pieces back
into one another.
So the true utility being in a state
is the reward you get in that state,
plus the discount of all the reward
you're going to get at that point,
which, of course, is defined as
the utility you're going to get for
the states that you see, but
each one of those is defined similarly.
And so the utility you will get for
s double prime say will also be further
discounted but since it's multiplied
by gamma that will be gamma squared and
then s triple prime will be gamma cubed,
and
so that's basically just unrolling
this notion of utility up here.
>> Okay so now it seems like all
the pieces are in one place.
>> Right.
And so it would be nice if we were done.
And I'm going to say that we're
not just one step closer, but
you can see an oncoming light and
it is not an oncoming train, okay.
So
>> Yeah,
this seems like a really
important equation.
>> It is, in fact, it's so
important, it's got a name.
You want to guess what the name is?
>> Bill
>> That's actually very close.
It's Bellman Equation.
>> Bellman equation
>> Esquire.
This equation was invented by a guy
named Bellman, and it turns out to be in
some sense the key equation for
solving MDPs and reinforcement learning.
>> Wow.
>> And it's actually even more
[INAUDIBLE] than it looks.
But basically, this is the fundamental
recursive equation that defines
the true value of being
in some particular state.
And it accounts for everything
that we care about in the MDP.
The utilities themselves deal with
the policy that we want to have,
the gammas are discount, and
all the rewards are here.
The transition matrix is here,
and the actions or
all the actions we're going to take.
So basically the whole MDP is
referenced inside of here and allows
us by determining utilities, to always
know what's the best action to take.
What's the one that's going to
maximize the utility?
So if we can figure out
the answer to this equation,
the utilities of all the states, we per
force know what the optimal policy is.
It becomes very easy.
So we've sort of taken all
that neat stuff about NDPs and
stuck it in a single equation.
Bellman was a very smart guy.
>> So was he the same Bellman
from the curse of dimensionality?
>> Yes.
>> Cool.
>> There can be only one Bellman.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Actually,
are there any more Bellmans?
I don't think so, I think that they
retired, like retiring a jersey.
They retired his name.
I could've sworn that I saw one
at the last hotel that I went to.
>> It was probably the same one.
Oh, I get it.
Hotel, Bellman, that's really good.
>> Very good.
>> Okay good.
Well, so now that we've killed
that as much as we could,
let's see if we can actually
solve this equation,
which since this is clearly the key
equation since it has a name, okay?
>> Yeah, that would be cool.
Especially because it looks like,
if you could solve this,
you could solve it, right?
because then you have u.
You could just plug the u in and
get the u out.
>> Right.
And once you have the u in, and
you get the u out,
then you got the policy.
>> Right.
>> For u.
>> It's always been for u.
>> [LAUGH] It's for us,
Michael, it's for us.